I got a Kindle I'm very excited about I
downloaded a like a 500 page book in 10
seconds which blew me away I mean
compared to the delivery system I grew
up with the Scholastic Book Club it took
me 10 days to get my mom to write out a
check 10 business days that was her
policy and yeah you would bring in the
check the last Friday in September they
delivered the book senior of high school
I got my diploma and a hop on pop on the
same day I feel my verbal suffered I my
parents are from the the greatest
generation there they're amazing they
survived World War two the Great
Depression the polio epidemic pulp in
their orange juice
unregulated unlimited pulp in their
orange juice never said a word about it
never complained then wheat came along
took one sip ah what was that there's
there's orange in my orange juice do
something now and they did Tropicana
rolled right over got rid of all the
pulp all right the pulp is gone you
crazy people are you happy the pulp is
gone there's no more pulp
are you happy now can we keep some pulp
how much is how much is some pulp I
don't know a pinch of pulp a dash of OPA
I don't know we'll whine until you get
it perfect how does that sound that's
what we do we wine everything into
perfection the phone my parents had a
very different experience with the phone
neat this is good they used to talk to
people on it and to me the phone is this
this seldom-used
app on my phone
[Music]
and and if you if you use it on me oh
god help you I how dare you I am furious
when I get a phone call you you text me
first to see if I'm even taking phone
calls today I'll text you back with a
window but we we are relentless with how
we want the phone to be better like we
also we want all our music all our music
on the phone you you want all your music
on the phone no I'm sorry I mean I
misspoke we want all the music every
song ever on our phone now okay but like
what are you willing to pay for that
nothing nothing might offer is this
nothing as it has it made us more
comfortable yes
lay here certainly I did the laziest
thing the other night I I bought a movie
that I own on DVD I bought it on
just so I wouldn't have to get out of
bed my DVD collection is there
it's there but my reasoning was I'm not
gonna be able to flick it into the I
said you know what if Shawshank
Redemption is is under $15 on iTune I'm
buying it $14.99 and sold I Anna and I
was thrilled it's downloads immediately
I watched it I enjoyed it so much
then I I made the mistake of telling my
older brother who's a miser and and he
was outraged yeah what are you doing
yeah we're from Boston so he has that
accent yeah what are you doing get what
are you doing buying a movie you already
home for $15 kid what are you doing pal
guy brother do it what are you doing kid
like what it's it's $15 what's the big
deal not adds up guy it adds up $15 here
$15 dad adds up adds up not my
philosophy let me tell you something and
pay attention cuz this is true it only
adds up if you add it up
[Applause]
you you will never be $15 away from your
dream house but you are always 15
dollars away from owning shawshank
redemption' on itunes so get busy living
or get busy dying thank you very much
you